when i was in my early teens  i stood up all night writing a  screenplay  and felt something to this day i swear i  could not get enough of  it was as close to the feeling of flying  as i have ever had  you know what i mean when  when you're trying to get the words on  paper and your three thoughts ahead of  yourself and it's a race to get it all  down before it goes back to where that's  ever that stuff originally comes from  and  it was called inspiration  and i actually made a movie from that  script i wrote all night and it was  called fire light  and it was truly an awful  movie but the process was what it was  all about  the experience of that obsessive focus  of having an idea and actually being  able to photograph it  that's been the magic potion for me ever  since